[Musique]
juni du nord qui borde avérée
luc de larochellière vous allez célébrer
le 30e anniversaire de votre tout
premier disque amère america ouais avec
un concert spécial en cadre de coup de
coeur francophone que l'hérédité l'album
en disques compacts et en vinyle
pourquoi c'est important pour vous de
souligner cet anniversaire pour deux
raisons parce que de 30 ans d'un bon
chiffre mais aussi parce que ce
disque-là amère america n'est plus
disponible dans son entièreté sous
aucune plateforme depuis plus de 15 ans
donc c'est une façon pour moi c'est un
peu pour la pérennité de la sphère le
dos de pour faire exister ce qui est un
peu là bah ousmane ma carrière et
aujourd'hui tu vois l'été passé j'étais
dans le gros show de la saint-jean sur
les plaines les pistes est beaucoup à
cause de ses chansons le plus précieux
ridicules que les gens ne puissent pas
avoir accès l'entièreté de l'album donc
on réduit de l'album on s'est dit tant
qu'à faire mais on va faire un show que
ça tombait bien dans le la programmation
de coup de coeur francophone
[Musique]
china
vous allez réédité en 2018 amère américa
en disques vinyles mais la légende vu
qu'en 1988 le premier pressage vinyle
était une catastrophe c'est vrai écoute
j'ai j'avais mis sur chez nous mais tu
as mis à breuil et ça se peut pas six
mois depuis le temps que j'attends de
faire un disque de stockage y avait de
la distorsion sur les s et là je vais
appeler la maison disque j'avais dis un
gros problème puisqu'on dessus c'est
clair c'est que le plan de pressage de
l'époque avait cassé la maîtrise et sans
nous avertir en avait fait une à partir
la version cd mauvaise et avait présenté
tous les dix comme ça donc
donc tous les gens qui ont été libérés
la l'époque ont acheté finalement une
mauvaise c'est la version parti d'une
mauvaise d'une mauvaise maîtrise on
s'était dit on voit les prochains
pressage on va rectifier la faire mais
il n'y a jamais eu de deuxième pressage
parce que c'était la fin du vinyle le
plan de pressage offert n'est pas très
longtemps après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cela permet la question suivante parce
que vous avez une chanson qui s'instille
cash c'est petit pour un artiste qui à
22 ans connaît le succès de façon
soudaine en instruments choix soit de
tout dépenser cet argent soit d'en
garder un peu pour ses vieux jours
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec vos
enfants j'étais jeune j'étais paul
legault le plus économe mais je pas non
plus plus grand consommateur au monde de
ce chocolat
le magasinage est définitivement pas mon
nom ma mère mon activité favorite
donc j'ai fait des bonds move j'ai été
conseillé par mon père à l'époque email
si tu peux acheter deux maisons achète
une maison j'ai acheté une maison et je
te dirai que c'est ce move l'homme a
permis de continuer ma carrière malgré
les hauts et les bas
je n'avais pas de gros problèmes de
consommation dans lequel vivent les
appareils de seconde
seul problème de consommation que vous
donnez lui si la cigarette j'ai dû
serrer glisse pratique lors beaucoup
plus tard mais faudrait dix ans donc
c'est bon c'est pas cher mais ce n'était
pas assez pour me mettre dans la rue
puis me faire brûler tout mais tout mais
avoir deux
jamais
[Musique]
je n'ai pas été exploité par manas
raison des fuseaux chancellor j'ai été
bien conseillés par mon père mon père
qui me conseille encore mis aujourd'hui
et puis donc c'est une des choses qui
m'a aidé et peut-être à continuer à
faire ce métier là malgré les le côté
montagnes russes de la fin en terminant
on dit qu'après votre tournée amer
américain vous nous préparez tout une
surprise
un deuxième disque avec votre conjoint
lisez de larochellière deuxième temps on
le fait un peu ce disque là en fait on
est en train de le faire lol on le fait
un peu parce qu'on dit que notre fils va
entrer à garderie qu'on pourra plus
tourner ensemble dans quelques années
et puis finalement en le faisant on se
rend compte que on a des mots dits de
bonnes chansons puisque c'est ça donc ce
mélange de passé et de présent
voilà c'est exactement ce qui s'en vient
[Musique]
non
merci merci beaucoup merci d
m